?
OR CAN WE HAVE A MUCH BETTER
WINTER IF WE USE ALL, ALL THE
TOOLS WE HAVE AVAILABLE TO US
NOW?
AND LET'S START WITH COVID
UPDATE VACCINES.
THEY'RE DESIGNED TO FIGHT A
SPECIFIC OMICRON STRAIN THAT'S
AS DOMINANT IN OUR COUNTRY RIGHT
NOW.
THIS IS REALLY A SERIOUS, GIANT
STEP FORWARD.
REMEMBER, OMICRON DID NOT EVEN
EXIST WHEN THE FIRST VACCINES
AGAINST COVID WERE DEVELOPED.
DIDN'T EVEN EXIST.
WE'RE ESPECIALLY FORTUNATE HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES BECAUSE MY
ADMINISTRATION MADE SURE WE'RE
THE FIRST COUNTRY IN THE WORLD
TO HAVE VACCINES THAT TARGET
MOST COMMON COVID STRAINS.
FOR AMERICANS OVER 5 YEARS OF
AGE WHO ARE FULLY VACCINATED OUR
NATION'S HEALTH EXPERTS
RECOMMEND THAT THEY GET THE
UPDATED COVID VACCINE ONCE A
YEAR.
IN OTHER WORDS, IT'S JUST LIKE
THE FLU SHOT.
AND IF YOU'RE FULLY VACCINATED,
GET ONE MORE COVID SHOT.
ONCE A YEAR.
THAT'S IT.
NOW SOME HIGH-RISK PEOPLE SUCH
AS ELDERLY AND IMMUNOCOMPROMISED
MAY NEED MORE THAN ONE COVID
SHOT.
BUT FOR MOST AMERICANS ONE COVID
SHOT EACH YEAR WILL BE ALL THEY
NEED.
AND IF YOU GET IT YOU'RE
PROTECTED.
AND IF YOU DON'T YOU'RE PUTTING
YOURSELF AND OTHER PEOPLE AT
UNNECESSARY RISK.
THE SHOT IS FREE.
IT'S WIDELY AVAILABLE.
AND CONVENIENTLY LOCATED.
JUST IN TIME FOR THE HOLIDAY
SEASON.
LOOK, OVER 20 MILLION OF OUR
FELLOW AMERICANS HAVE ALREADY
GOTTEN THE SHOT.
I'M CALLING ON ALL AMERICANS.
IT SEEMS LIKE I'M HAVING TO MAKE
THIS CASE AGAIN.
ALL AMERICANS TO GET THEIR SHOT
JUST AS SOON AS THEY CAN.
YOUR OLD VACCINE OR YOUR
PREVIOUS COVID INFECTION WILL
NOT GIVE YOU MAXIMUM PROTECTION.
LET ME BE AS PLAIN AS I CAN.
WE STILL HAVE HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
DYING EACH DAY FROM COVID IN
THIS COUNTRY.
HUNDREDS.
THAT NUMBER IS LIKELY TO RISE
THIS WINTER.
BUT THIS YEAR IS DIFFERENT FROM
THE PAST.
THIS YEAR NEARLY EVERY DEATH IS
PREVENTABLE.
LET ME SAY IT AGAIN.
NEARLY EVERY DEATH IS
PREVENTABLE.
SO GET UPDATED -- GET YOUR
UPDATED COVID SHOT.
NOW IS THE TIME TO DO IT.
BY HALLOWEEN IF YOU CAN.
THAT'S THE BEST TIME.
AND THAT WAY YOU CAN BE
PROTECTED FOR THE HOLIDAYS.
AND PLEASE, WHILE YOU'RE AT IT,
GET THE FLU SHOT.
HAVE YOUR KIDS GET THEIR FLU
SHOT.
YOU CAN GET THEM AT THE SAME
TIME YOU GET THE FLU SHOT AND
COVID AT THE SAME TIME.
EITHER YOUR DOCTOR'S OFFICE OR
ONE OF THE DRUGSTORES.
WE'RE ALREADY SEEING A RISE IN
FLU AND RSV AND OTHER
RESPIRATORY ILLNESSES,
ESPECIALLY AMONG YOUNG CHILDREN.
SO TAKE PRECAUTIONS, STAY SAFE.
YOU CAN SPEND THANKSGIVING WITH
FAMILY AND FRIENDS WITH A PEACE
OF MIND KNOWING THAT YOU'VE DONE
YOUR PART FOR EVERYONE'S
WELL-BEING.
MY ADMINISTRATION IS DOING OUR
PART.
WE'VE MADE THESE UPDATED
VACCINES EASY TO GET AND
AVAILABLE FOR FREE AT TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CONVENIENT
LOCATIONS.
THESE INCLUDE LOCAL PHARMACIES,
DOCTOR'S OFFICE, COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS, RURAL HEALTH
CLINICS THAT SERVE THE HARD TO
REACH AREAS IN AMERICA.
95%, 95% OF AMERICANS CAN FIND A
FREE UPDATED VACCINE WITHIN FIVE
MILES OF WHERE THEY LIVE.
YOU CAN GO TO VACCINES.GOV.
LET ME SAY THAT AGAIN.
GO TO VACCINES.GOV TO FIND A
LOCATION NEAR YOU.
AGAIN, I'M GOING TO SAY IT ONE
MORE TIME.
GO TO VACCINES.GOV TO FIND A
PLACE WHERE YOU CAN GET THE SHOT
NEAR YOU.
WE'RE WORKING WITH DOCTORS,
COMMUNITY GROUPS, FAITH LEADERS
AND COMPANIES.
LEADERS AT SOME OF OUR NATION'S
LARGEST PHARMACEUTICAL CHAINS, I
SAID, ARE STANDING BEHIND ME.
THEY'RE ALL STEPPING UP TO HELP
MORE PEOPLE GET VACCINATED.
SOME ARE OFFERING COUPONS WHEN
PEOPLE GET THEIR UPDATED COVID
SHOTS.
GET THE SHOT.
5, 10, $20 OFF YOUR DRUGSTORE
GROCERY PURCHASE -- OR GROCERY
PURCHASE NEXT TIME AT THE SAME
TIME YOU GET THE SHOT.
SOME ARE MAKING IT EASY FOR YOU
JUST TO WALK IN AND GET YOUR
VACCINE RIGHT AWAY, INCLUDING ON
NIGHTS AND WEEKENDS.
AND OTHERS FROM THE PRIVATE
SECTOR ARE STEPPING UP AS WELL.
INCLUDING DELIVERING COVID
TREATMENTS RIGHT TO PEOPLE'S
HOMES FOR FREE.
NOW, WHAT DO YOU DO IF YOU THINK
YOU HAVE COVID?
WELL, PLEASE, GET TESTED SO YOU
CAN BE TREATED.
WE MAILED OUT HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF FREE TEST KITS
EARLIER THIS YEAR.
WE HAD TO PAUSE THE PROGRAM
BECAUSE UNFORTUNATELY SOME OF
OUR FRIENDS IN CONGRESS FAILED
TO CONTINUE TO FUND THE COVID
RESPONSE.
BUT IF YOU HAVE ALREADY USED UP
THESE FREE TESTS, THAT'S OKAY.
WE HAVE REQUIRED HEALTH
INSURANCE -- WE'VE REQUIRED
HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES TO
COVER FREE AT-HOME TESTS, AIFT
EIGHT TESTS PER PERSON PER
MONTH.
FOLKS ON MEDICARE AND MEDICAID
CAN GET FREE AT-HOME TESTS AS
WELL.
AND WE'VE MADE FREE TESTING
WIDELY AVAILABLE IN COMMUNITIES.
AND THEN IF YOU TEST POSITIVE
FOR COVID GET TREATED.
WE HAVE AMAZING TREATMENTS
AVAILABLE NOW.
AND IT CAN HELP STOP KOIFD
COVID INFECTIONS FROM TURNING
INTO SERIOUS ILLNESS.
WE'RE THE ONLY LARGE COUNTRY IN
THE WORLD THAT MADE PAXLOVID --
PAXLOVID WIDELY AVAILABLE FOR
FREE.
YOU CAN GET IT PRESCRIBED BY
YOUR DOCTOR OR AT THOUSANDS OF
TEST TO TREAT SITES OR EVEN FROM
YOUR LOCAL PHARMACIST.
PICK IT UP FOR FREE AT YOUR
PHARMACY.
IT'S A PILL.
IT'S EASY.
PAXLOVID CAN SAVE YOUR LIFE.
IT'S WORTH IT.
AND HERE'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
VIRTUALLY EVERY COVID DEATH IN
AMERICA IS PREVENTABLE.
VIRTUALLY EVERY ONE.
ALMOST EVERYONE WHO WILL DIE
FROM COVID THIS YEAR WILL NOT BE
UP TO DATE ON THEIR SHOTS OR
THEY WILL NOT HAVE TAKEN
PAXLOVID WHEN THEY GOT SICK.
WE'VE MADE THE VACCINES FREE AND
AVAILABLE.
WE'VE MADE THE TESTS FREE AND
WE'VE MADE PAXLOVID FREE AND
AVAILABLE.
PLEASE USE THEM.
USE THEM.
AND ENCOURAGE YOUR FRIENDS AND
LOVED ONES AND NEIGHBORS TO USE
THEM AS WELL.
IT CAN SAVE A LIFE.
TO EMPLOYERS HELP YOUR EMPLOYEES
GET VACCINATED.
SET UP A VACCINE CLINIC IN YOUR
BUILDING.
GIVE PEOPLE TIME OFF TO GET IT
IF NECESSARY.
SHARE GOOD CLEAR INFORMATION.
JUST LIKE YOU DO FOR THE FLU
SHOTS.
TO SCHOOL AND COLLEGE LEADERS.
HELP YOUR COMMUNITIES GET
VACCINATED THIS FALL.
HOST ON-SITE CLINICS BEFORE
THANKSGIVING.
AND TO OUR FRIENDS IN CONGRESS
IT'S TIME TO STEP UP WITH
MUCH-NEEDED COVID FUNDING.
HELP US STAY AHEAD OF THE VIRUS
AND KEEP OUR COMMUNITIES GOING
STRONG WITH FREE VACCINES, FREE
TESTS AND WIDELY AVAILABLE
TREATMENTS AS WE'VE DONE SO FAR.
SOME OF OUR FRIENDS IN CONGRESS
SAY WE DON'T NEED COVID FUNDING.
BUT THEY SAY THERE'S REALLY NO
REASON THAT THE GOVERNMENT
SHOULD BE PAYING FOR IT.
I STRONGLY DISAGREE.
STRONGLY DISAGREE.
THIS IS A GLOBAL HEALTH
EMERGENCY.
IF WE REALLY WANT TO PUT COVID
BEHIND US, WE HAVE TO KEEP UP
THE FIGHT TOGETHER.
WE CAN'T LEAVE PEOPLE TO FACE IT
ALONE.
SOME MEMBERS OF CONGRESS SAY
THEY DON'T WANT TO MOVE BEYOND
COVID BUT THEY DON'T WANT TO
SPEND THE MONEY TO DO IT.
WE CAN'T HAVE IT BOTH WAYS.
THE FUNDING WE SEEK IS CRITICAL.
TO CONTINUE THE WORK TO DEVELOP
AND PURCHASE THE MOST EFFECTIVE
TREATMENTS AND VACCINES AGAINST
COVID.
IT'S IMPORTANT.
NOW, I WANT TO SPEAK DIRECTLY TO
THOSE WITH SPECIAL CONDITIONS.
NEW VARIANTS MAY MAKE SOME
EXISTING PROTECTIONS INEFFECTIVE
FOR THE IMMUNOCOMPROMISED.
SADLY, THIS MEANS YOU MAY BE AT
A SPECIAL RISK THIS WINTER.
SO I URGE YOU, I URGE YOU TO
CONSULT YOUR DOCTOR ON THE RIGHT
STEPS TO PROTECT YOURSELF.
TAKE EXTRA PRECAUTIONS.
I ALSO WANT TO SAY THIS.
AS WE ENTER THIS NEW MOMENT IN
THE BATTLE AGAINST COVID, LET'S
USE IT TO START FRESH AS A
COUNTRY, TO PUT ALL THE OLD
BATTLES OVER COVID BEHIND US.
TO PUT ALL THE PARTISAN POLITICS
ASIDE.
WE'VE ALREADY LOST OVER 1
MILLION AMERICANS TO COVID.
OVER 1 MILLION AMERICANS TO
COVID.
WE CAN DO SO MUCH NOW TO REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO DIE
FROM THIS TERRIBLE DISEASE.
WE HAVE THE TOOLS.
WE HAVE THE VACCINES.
WE HAVE THE TREATMENTS.
NONE OF THIS IS ABOUT POLITICS.
IT'S ABOUT YOUR HEALTH.
AND THE HEALTH OF YOUR LOVED
ONES.
I'LL CLOSE WITH THIS.
OVER THE PAST 20 MONTHS MY
ADMINISTRATION HAS LEFT NO STONE
UNTURNED TO MAKE LIFE-SAVING
TOOLS WIDELY AVAILABLE AND
EASILY ACCESSIBLE.
NOW COVID CASES ARE DOWN BY MORE
THAN 80% FROM WHEN I TOOK
OFFICE.
COVID DEATHS ARE DOWN NEARLY
90%.
AND NOW WE'RE IN THE LONGEST
STRETCH SINCE THE VIRUS EMERGED
WHEN OUR HOSPITALS ARE NOT
OVERRUN WITH SEVERELY ILL COVID
PATIENTS.
THAT DIDN'T JUST HAPPEN.
IT TOOK A COMBINATION OF
INCREDIBLY EFFECTIVE VACCINES,
TESTS AND TREATMENTS TO GET US
THERE.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST PUBLIC HEALTH
EFFORTS EVER UNDERTAKEN IN THIS
COUNTRY.
BUT TOGETHER WE DID IT.
AND LET'S KEEP DOING IT.
LET'S KEEP GOING.
THIS FALL GET YOUR COVID SHOT
AND GET YOUR FLU SHOT.
IT'S SIMPLE.
IT'S EASY.
FOR MOST AMERICANS IT'S ONE OF
THE COVID SHOTS PER YEAR, ONCE A
YEAR, THAT'S GOING TO BE
REQUIRED.
AND IT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING YOU CAN DO.
SO THANK YOU.
AND NOW I'LL SHOW YOU JUST HOW
EASY IT IS TO GET THAT SHOT.
YOU'RE NOT GIVING ME THE SHOT.
>> NO, I'M NOT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WHAT AM I DOING?
LEFT ARM?
>> YES, SIR.
>> ALL RIGHT
.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, IS COVID STILL
A NATIONAL EMERGENCY?
>> A NECESSITY TO DEAL WITH TO
MAKE SURE IT DOESN'T BECOME ONE.
>> WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO THE
SAUDIS ON OIL, URGING THE U.S.
NOT TO USE RESERVES?
>> SIR, DO YOU THINK IT WAS A
MISTAKE FOR NEW YORK TO WITHDRAW
ITS MANDATE FOR VACCINES?
>> SAY IT AGAIN.
>> DO YOU THINK IT WAS A MISTAKE
FOR NEW YORK TO WITHDRAW ITS